the talk is about the title of the talk
which I unfortunately had only two days
to prepare and not full days at that
because I have to satisfy clients and
they get crazy sometimes makers hackers
and the personal computer revolution now
I sort of expected that I would have
been introduced as in terms of how I fit
in there and I I don't want to say too
much but I have to say something which
is to say that you can look me up in
fact there's a website that I've created
for self-promotion and his URL is listed
on the website here Lee fells and Stein
calm and most of my story can be read
there I was a founder of Osborne
corporate Computer Corporation but that
was rather late in the game in 1981 in
1975 I was an original participant in
the homebrew Computer Club and by the
fourth meeting that year I had taken
over the running the meeting as what I
call the Toastmaster I consider the
meeting process to be one of my most
productive designs because at least 23
companies formed out of that meeting
including Apple and what became
InfoWorld
before that I had explored in the
nascent computer or personal computer
underground which were people meeting in
potlucks and so forth talking about the
day when there would be personal
computers and what would they be like
and how might they be designed and I
came to that from my experience with the
first social first public social media
community memory in 1973 where I
encountered the problem of how to make
computer hardware
survive in a public-access environment
so my thinking evolved along those lines
coming from social media basically now
and along the way the if if by chance
you use a personal computer then you
will be using the architecture of
display thank you very much mister or is
it dr. Mia we'll explain that later the
then you are using the arc to display
architecture that I specified in 1974
and sold for fifty cents a copy the
specification that is not the
architecture so that explains the
description that I was somehow
responsible for the design of the
personal computer I'll argue that
separately that's not relevant here
we're now seeing the phenomenon of the
what's called the maker movement and
this seems like a kind of up to date
Crafts movement where people will just
like to build things and get together
and talk about them and show them off
and so forth and it's getting more and
more press now that there are quote 3d
printers which there had been beforehand
but they were rather expensive but now
they're very cheap relatively low
quality but therefore available printers
the MakerBot let's write that down
because I couldn't even remember the
name until now
whoops you know we're over here MakerBot
I'll get under there there we go
and now there is a great deal of talk
about how you'll be everyone will have a
3d printer on there in their home and we
will make of whatever we need and so
forth this also has been one of the
subjects of the I believe it's Neil
Stevenson book the diamond age where
there are compilers matter compilers and
that leads to a whole science fiction
universe so are we entering this science
fiction universe right now in which
every consumer is a producer and that
everything will be manufactured with
this marvelous new added additive
process well for those of us who've been
involved in the manufacture of things
you can't just write off the subtractive
processes drilling holes and a few
things like that but it's got a lot of
press and the question is is this a
revolution or what where is this they're
just irrelevant hobbyists wasting time
and it really doesn't matter now the
interesting part is that we've been
there before because in the first few
years of the personal computer industry
before there was a quote killer app
there was that exact critique levelled
at us we don't understand why you're
working with these little tiny 8-bit
machines with almost no memory why not
go find a real computer you can play
with and we don't see what you're doing
and you can't even explain why you're
doing it the major two applications that
were mentioned whenever someone asked
what are you put what do you plan to run
on your home computer the major two
applications where I'm going balancing
my checkbook and managing recipe files I
don't believe that anybody ever
chillie did those two things at least
for many years until there were programs
that could handle them but this was the
justification and it was transparently
false but the it didn't stop us is the
point we were at it for some other
reason I would suggest that people look
up John Mark Hoffs book than what the
Dormouse said for more discussion of
this reading that book to which I was a
contributor in terms of interviews made
me understand that the person who
marketed the personal computer before it
existed was Stewart Brand through the
Whole Earth Catalog
by you know marketing is the sale of the
idea of a product so you don't really
need to have a product and it helps a
great deal if you do the marketing
before you create the product and that's
what happened there you can go read back
issues of the Whole Earth Catalog or
just look at their statement of purpose
in which they're saying we are as gods
so we might as well get good at it I
think that's still a little a little
arrogant to declare oneself as gods we
act as gods though that might have been
more accurate and the important issue
for the whole earth catalogue was sowing
the idea that people who felt that they
could have no serious effect on
technology actually had a need to learn
their way into whatever technologies
they felt was important and so they were
talking about knives and stoves and so
forth and started out well I'm not going
to get into the history of the of Whole
Earth Catalog that
take too long but they were talking to
an audience of hippies and trying to
convince them to get their hands dirty
with technology and interesting well
that's not nut makers yet but close and
when the personal computer arrived and
the first article for it described it as
a mini computer the nobody knew what to
do with it after all it was just a box
with lights and switches and had almost
nothing in it in fact a friend of mine
Bob Marsh with whom I rented a garage in
the hopes of designing some products
putting them out noticed there was
nothing in the box and he went into
business to put things to fit in it to
fill the box and I helped him so we have
the Maker Faire
now there's has I don't know how many
people here have been to the Maker Faire
of course I can't pull the audience but
and online but it seems one one way of
looking at it is as a kind of test run
for Burning Man machinery you get lots
of flames and so forth and psychedelic
looking monsters clattering along and
little muffins on little scooters that
you can get into and drive as packs and
it's really Alice in Wonderland stuff
also there's Tesla coils and robot wars
going on in one corner I think in one
place they have a tank and you have
naval robot wars we can buy Japanese
electronic kits with vacuum tubes in
them and so forth all pretty marvelous
and there's a big section with just
plain arts and crafts like needlework
and so forth that's all considered part
of it now so it
what is this supposed to be to mean it's
it's is this the future and I I don't
know I don't think so but back in the
70s there were some people who felt that
we would make every kid a hacker that
everybody who had a personal computer
would be have it in order to quote write
good code that's what bike magazines
basic purpose was and so we would all be
compiling and so forth and I don't know
quite why but that didn't matter
now we it was always and is still in
this case a very interesting show an
attractive phenomenon and the in both
cases they were dealing with
reorganizing technology-based production
that sounds extremely pretentious and it
is when you say it that way
but people had an urge to gain
increasing control over the process of
development of technologies that effect
of them are potentially affected them
the opening shot in the quote personal
computer revolution did not occur in
1975 but in 1973 in a magazine that was
aimed at radio and TV repair technicians
something we don't seem to have anymore
it was a trade I had learned as a kid
and it was the TV typewriter whereby you
could type on a homemade keyboard and
show your letters and numbers whatever
you typed show up on your television
screen this promised a certain
capability of control of both digital
technology and video technology if he
could control it went on your screen
well this was quite something and they
got an overwhelming response they they
expected twenty paid responses for plans
they got 10,000 and it was gettin the
friend of the Bob Marshall rented that
garage with me he had actually gone
ahead and attempted to build it and I
stressed the word attempted because he
did not fully succeed many people did
not fully succeed and learned digital
electronics and in fact some analog
electronics to the way that was designed
it was both
therefore the you know I'm increasing
the understanding hands-on visceral
understanding of technologies was a
desired but not expressed goal for
people who participated certainly in the
personal computer effort and I presume
in the maker effort and so moving from
the position of being simply a consumer
a user a subject of the technology doing
things the way the technology is
designed and it's designed by other
people who are somewhere else who knows
now they're in China to being people who
can define the technologies that they
have to deal with it this I think was
the attraction and in fact it is a
pent-up kind of demand that's been
building ever since we've had industrial
society now both examples were subject
to ridicule and you know the PCs are
just toy computers you know what can
they do after all and they couldn't do
anything and so the 3d printers we can
say oh look this MakerBot thing it's
almost made of cardboard you know is if
you look at it it breaks down constantly
you have to keep trimming it to make it
work right and a precision is not much
what's the point open question that is
what we're going to explore here and of
course the people who are doing it we're
simply not qualified when we had the
meetings of the homebrew
pewter club we pretty much did not
receive visitors from on high from Xerox
PARC and so forth why would they come to
a place like that and talk with people
who did not know most of what they knew
these are people who were trying to get
a hold of or may build or otherwise find
a computer that they could do something
where they could learn their way in
anybody who was really a professional in
the field already had that access and
and didn't need to involve themselves in
this grungy stuff so I could say that
the people who were attending those
sessions were second-string and below
and it included a significant stratum of
physicians who probably should have been
engineers they had their money available
and they knew how to study their way
into something and that was the largest
group that I could identify and there
were also the ham radio people but you
can always expect them so it was all
dismissed as mere hobbyists and crafters
and just don't bother about it it's not
going to amount to anything
well there's that's taking a kind of a
static view of okay there's these people
there's these things I see them and I
judge them and that's it but what's
going on is a process involving the
people people learn this was a major way
for them to learn us to learn in a way
you know I learned a lot myself and
we're developing different models that
happened in computers and I think will
happen in in the maker universe for
developing different models of
product definition market definition and
development of expectations this is
something that anybody in marketing
should pay attention to because that's
what they that's their product as
expectations and definitions for the
first four years like I say there was no
quote killer app there's no real
justification for in software for a
personal computer then we had VisiCalc
and then people would come up to
Frankston and Bricklin and when they ran
and when they were found out who they
were accountants would come up to them
and congratulate him you're the guys
that made accounting fun and in fact
they made modeling spreadsheet modeling
as close to fun as it can be for those
of us who had to do it and didn't really
want to I planned the whole project on
there Osborn super calc spreadsheet and
was really quite the base by about how
you could you know alter the numbers and
everything changed add and so forth now
we expect that but that was brand new
and you know the whole idea of making it
fun is a very powerful element in making
a technology alive let's say so the
in both cases we're taking serious stuff
technology and turning it into toys
things you play with now that the
computer professionals of the 70s really
did not like that one of them herb
Grolsch made a visit to the homebrew
club I think in late 75 and was writing
columns for computer world I believe he
was the editor of computer world at that
time and that was the really serious
computer paper it was you know IBM all
the way and so forth that had already
Mike fell he he came through it column
before his visit said I heard that these
guys are actually sharing software I
believe that when I see it the column
after was like my god these people are
sharing software they've got to stop
doing this didn't make any difference to
us we really didn't care what he said
but the process of play and the process
of making technologies are in fact not
as separate and ought not to be separate
or considered as separate and opposition
play is a very fundamental note a
motivation play sport whatever sport is
universal throughout humanity and it has
no rational justification yes you can
say that if you gain status through
sport then you can gain a reproductive
advantage that's what this socio
biologists would say but there are other
ways to do that and that aren't as hard
on the body still people do it and in
fact people play with tools when they're
not supposed to it's a major source of
accidents with tools and if you're
planning the use of tools you have to
make some take account of the fact that
somebody's going to figure out a way to
play with this thing and it could hurt
somebody it's there it happens and it's
how we instinctively learn as kids and I
believe that we never grow out of it
so the looking at the the makers
phenomenon as just crafts
well alright that's what is crafts but
it's play with physical things that you
put together okay and so now adding in
additional technologies simply changes
the what you're playing with not doesn't
really change the process and it's
something that just arose you know it's
not like somebody put a stake in the
ground and said now people are going to
play they don't have to do that
it's built in so the claims that arise
from observing this can of course be
overblown the I for the little bit of
research I did for this talk I saw the
article they took video talk actually by
chambers is it Paul Chambers or I don't
remember the first name he's the editor
of Wired and he's very enthusiastic in
fact he started a little business
himself making some stuff and he
believes that and he has I heard this
before everybody's going to have a 3d
printer on their desk okay yeah thanks
we know what way this goes it's it it
isn't that everybody's going to have a
3d printer but there will be 3d printers
and their successors available as things
go forward now some of his statements
are of course quite perceptive and and I
have to agree with him which is to say
that this the the meaning of the
phenomenon is that it lowers the
barriers to entry into design and
production and so yes things will still
be made in countries like China but you
no longer will have to guarantee an
order of a million parts to get anything
the minimum is already going down as I
have recently discovered of course you
still have to deal with the fact that
it's being done so far away by people
you never meet etc but those are that's
mere reality not not concept the you'll
be able to according to chambers you'll
deal they'd be able to deal in
quantities of ten thousand but if ten
thousand why not one thousand why not
one hundred at a certain point as well
it's all a matter of the fixed costs
like transportation is not exactly a
fixed cost because it the varies of wait
I guess getting the fixed costs down and
what are the fixed costs the fixed costs
are the cost of running the organization
that is creating the product and there
are plenty of ways of spreading that out
of reducing the thickness of that
organization it's not as if things have
to be done on the price models that that
currently exist if you can come through
with say a hundred clients each of whom
has their own design and which who used
standardized file structures and so
forth through in order to express that
design and if you deal with them if you
can aggregate this you can get someone
with a serious factory in China to pay
attention now I'm not saying that I've
done this but I'm saying that this is
how it can be done what you don't do is
tell the people who come who would come
to you - oh no talk to that factory
they will get turned down but if you can
aggregate them and work with them
closely to make sure that their
requirements fit with the capabilities
but you're performing an intermediary it
function there that the factory simply
is not equipped to do and so this is
what's coming I believe yes production
some production will be moving back up
here on meaning will be setting up again
in the u.s. to work at smaller scale
production and some will stay overseas
this all has to do with factors that
involve supply chains and relationships
and so forth and all of that changes the
issues of well mass production are going
to yield to these sorts of structures
right now whatever gets produced is
produced because somebody puts a certain
amount of money up it also is produced
that way because it's not that different
from what's being produced otherwise
originally you have to you can draw a
matrix of features and quantity and so
forth
and when you move from one to the other
it's like your opponent on a chess board
you can only make one move in one
direction what's that you can't move
from here over to the other corner and
have it work within the manufacturing
structure that and marketing structure
that currently exists well of course
those structures are human structures
they can change the issue of product
lifetime and obsolescence works both
ways products don't last long enough and
again products stick around too long
some people want the newer newer things
and will
pay for it and some people want to hold
on to the familiar old things and don't
mind if they don't have the newer thing
well as it stands now in general and
within a product line and or there's a
roadmap and so forth and you well try to
buy a small memory chip today it can't
be done they don't make them anymore oh
yes you can buy something out of
collectors stocks but not for anything
that needs any quantity so we can see
that as long as there is a market that
is aggregated in other words that you
deal with a relatively small number of
channels to get things moving out into
the market its viable long as the money
flows and so forth the managerial
structure involved in handling these
decisions does not have to be there to
any significant extent if the
aggregation is external it's only when
you're a GM or something like that and
then you have piles and piles of
management making god-knows-what
decisions which result in a two-year
product cycle at the fastest then you
that's kind of set up for competition
from somebody who doesn't have to meet
those kind of managerial requirements
and then there's responsiveness to the
the customer feedback I bought an
ironing board at one point and the thing
fell over so wisely
I called or otherwise contacted the
number on the little paper that you
normally throw away and said my ironing
board fell over I'm gonna have to take
it back they said we'll set we'll send
you a new one and I got a new one with a
broadened stance
which hasn't yet fallen over and it's
like they weren't expecting and they
mean they did not as far as I can tell
this was an this was not happening every
day because if it was they weren't going
to send free ironing boards but I think
the the let's just put it this way there
are many companies I can think of that
would have had a procedure all in place
to make sure that that that request was
answered courteously and then ignored so
I saved the cost of an ironing board but
the perception of product value goes up
when you have a a responsive structure
so well we're those of when you think
there's a responsive structure if you
didn't if they have one and you don't
know it then well yes right point
conceded or they you think they have one
and they don't you get the same value
that's possible but that's a different
lecture that's a dealing in perceptions
and part of us is dealing in perceptions
no no question about that
you know think about what what would
someone who was in the software market
suffer industries who in in the 1960s
and 70s a about the today's software
market what would they say about the
99-cent app in some ways I was not the
computer person he was data processor
that's what animation and those those
things were about they were about batch
processing and they were big on
efficiency they did not believe in our
interaction I mean I could
I believe when I entered the workforce
how anti interaction a lot of my
colleagues were now how interaction is
threatening well it's not like that too
but actually I found a wonderful paper
by our friend Knuth entitled the art toy
programs useful and he's a big proponent
of games and toy problems excellent
I got a check for that you got a check
out of other typos oh I say the law a
law you know that's all we have
I'm the one who's supposed to be
bragging here not you but consider this
I mean how radically the market and
software has changed and the old
definition of software yes it's biggest
move from data processing who individual
applications were apps you know it's
like things that make things happen on
little things you hold in your hand this
was if somebody had had to make that
leap as if they were a time traveler it
would be very difficult for them to
really grasp what what the situation was
like well we're going to be getting
closer to that situation the major
aspect here is I think the the
empowerment of the of the creative
impulse which is definitely present I
mean where graffiti come from it's not
pleasant but it's still creative
definitely an impulse situation but more
than that the impulse to increase in X
and share and extend knowledge there's a
few places actually we can put the the
this in there
TechShop maker faire and Noisebridge
TechShop in for those who don't know and
i guess that's my point to speak to
those who don't know originated in
Mountain View it's basically a machine
shop where you pay a monthly used to be
100 it's probably a little more by now
dollar membership fee and you can come
in at any time and you can get trained
in the use of the machines which do
require training I was playing with
those things you'll lose a hand or
something but they have done a wonderful
job of providing an environment within
which that becomes possible so with
somebody who really does not know how
things are made we'll learn first hand
how things are fabricated in fact that's
I can't say it's completely but it
started out certainly being all
subtractive cutting metal and so forth
or plastic by now I'm sure they have 3d
printers too and you get to see what
they can do versus what other things can
do no better way to learn the maker
faire occurs at essentially Memorial Day
and of May but now it's May 16th through
I believe 18th at the San Mateo County
Fairgrounds and there's one in September
in New York had in Queens that is I
highly recommend it it costs money to
attend $30 or there abouts but the
people watching is wonderful because
there's a lot of people more or less
like you who are encountering a lot of
things for the first time and it's very
interesting to see those things also I
mean if you were there alone it would
still be interesting but not nearly as
interesting is there with thousands of
people and the noise bridge is an
example of one of the early generation
hackerspaces
that's in San Francisco and they are a
Anarkali anarchic Lee run I suppose
organization there was a point at which
I got the idea of what amounts to the
hackerspace and how the little birds of
a feather session on it and Jacob
Appelbaum who was one of the founders of
noise debris showed up and he was there
to say this is the way to do it because
they were doing it great having an idea
that somebody has already implemented it
validates the idea but it's not it's one
way of doing it which I consider to be
highly intriguing to say the least
somebody's got to keep it organized and
I suppose they do but if people can just
show up no membership doesn't cost
anything and there's tools to use
there's people who will presumably teach
you how to use them and some stock of
parts and somehow it doesn't fall apart
it sort of works
there's also unless somewhat more
organized fashion hacker dojo they've
got a website they're a 501c3 and they
are just as of today moved into a new
space in Mountain View interestingly
while they started in a set of cauldron
garage shops and it had previously been
a stained-glass call it a factory or a
workshop there's plenty of interesting
stained glass around they began trying
to define themselves as a club and you
paid a monthly membership fee and you
could come in and basically use the
place for technology development for the
mostly soft work lots and lots of
classes were held there and then he also
had events you know parties and so forth
and the city eventually came down and
said now you have to have
other you have to meet these
qualifications if you're going to have
all these people in here and a solution
for that after about a year's worth of
effort fundraising and back and forth
was that they rented another building
but they kept the old one because there
were always people who started up there
they started got the met the people they
needed to meet worked up the idea for
the project for the probe for the
product and started developing then they
said can we sort of camp out here and
make this our startup well the answer
was no because a lot of other people
wanted to use that space and that is
fundamentally what that old space is now
going to be used for they're going to be
leasing it out to anybody who shows up
who can put up the money I suppose I
don't know that there's any decision
process involved I mean obviously if
you're going to be doing something
that's dangerous they need to know about
and they'll pass judgment on it so they
have a new place I was just over there
last night helping to put together the
the work benches for the hardware shop
and it's very pretty
so hacker dojo as the name implies is
this sort of a software workout studio
you might say and there is a hardware
component to it who knows what is going
on the the whole universe of certainly
iOS devices and their applications got a
big boost gets a boost from from places
like hacker dojo the fellow who is
working on the software for the project
that I have to do right now and I would
always find him in the dojo whenever I
went in there I want to go into the
hardware shop and there it would be and
no matter what you were talking about he
would soon be joining in the
conversation and trying to point out why
he knew better
this is a common problem and apparently
he did that for the better part of a
year and put together enough contacts to
start basically to go into business both
creating iOS products and contracting
out in the development of the mostly
software for that and I've been involved
with him both ways as a contractor so
the these kinds of spaces these are you
call have to call it public if you just
have to Punggol up a little money to be
there it's public enough it's not like
somebody is has to decide has to you
know turn thumbs up or thumbs down on
you and so that kind of public space is
quite valuable because it's focused in a
certain area focused in the area of
technology there's plenty of other such
public spaces that need to be empowered
further and my particular project
throughout my career seems to have been
focused on working out technologies that
empower public spaces for this kind of
purpose well let me end right there I've
run off the end of my notes and let's
see what questions might happen to all
of those places memberships I've been to
Noisebridge
I've shown at Maker Faire and I just do
not see this as the cutting edge of
technology or leading to the future in a
useful way big tech shop has good
machinery which is basically used to do
arts and crafts stuff there's like some
one guy is building a nozzle for an X
Prize second stage rocket but that's
about as advanced as it gets that
there's a group that says design in
Silicon Valley made in Silicon Valley
and what they're making are are cheapy
little plastic things to attach
an iphone to your car dashboard with a
suction cup this is pathetic
Oh hacker dojo if they had a good
machine learning flux III took that
whole thing but mostly what I saw going
on there is a couple there people who
rent space there and they do their
business there there are people who
build I mean they have a thing kind of
surface about soldering station wherever
saying but anybody use it most of my
some people having LAN parties because
they have lots of tables with electrical
outlets um Maker Faire is an arts and
crafts show really if you show them
you're not selling something you're
you're acting is free entertainment for
the vendors
no one's rich is cool oh good art
projects come out of there but you know
people been doing cool our projects for
a long time oh but I do not see this as
the beginnings of something like that
for the personal computer revolution I
mean the real world I mean people have
been saying that for years there was
this big boom in the 50s for
do-it-yourself and where did that go
well listen I see something in you we're
talking about should be the first
computers and we're gonna do recipe
files and balance their checkbooks and I
try and we also had to learn basic and
stuff so a lot of the reason people
bought personal computers they thought
they could play a game or something like
that but they soon found out they hadn't
know how to program
to get anything done and you want it but
somebody's got a program well now we
have these 3d printers that are becoming
more populous not ubiquitous yet and the
first thing we'll see we'll find out the
buy one is you gotta learn a 3d CAD
programming language to do anything with
it and that's not as much fun it's
watching this thing spit out pistols or
whatever you think with the damn thing
but what you're going to wind up with
hopefully is the people that are now
fluent in this new language and when and
if 3d printers and I hope they get to be
as good as on Star Trek or something you
know well now have at least of big
beginnings of a language so that
somebody could talk to it to make
something we're having VisiCalc did
start with VisiCalc and then apple 2
came out the Apple 2 came out and it was
pretty pathetic but then it's a
platformer and I think we're a ways off
from getting a 3d printer that's as good
as anything on Star Trek but I think
we'll get something better that we have
now everything all the criticisms you
leveled a
are pretty much true B were similar to
criticisms levelled in the first few
years of the personal computer industry
and I think what I was saying about the
fact that people when they get involved
in this learn that they have to be they
have to learn more about other things
that work like little languages and so
forth it's in that kind of dynamic
that you get beyond what you see on hand
if you see what I mean in other words
yes you didn't see this or that like
it's true it's not there yet but the
people are who are there by learning why
they need to go further than that you
know they're one of the the claims that
I find somewhat laughable about the 3d
printers is oh well they'll be able to
manufacture their themselves and
therefore self-replicate well anybody
who knows about tolerance stacking knows
that that is hopeless somebody might
come up with some solution there but I'm
not sure what it's going to be the you
know making multiple generation copies
is the example in two dimensions so
there's one of the points I was trying
to make here was that it is over solved
at the present time and in fact the
there is much more that has to be done
before it becomes
call it viable if you cover forever
comes more than play but I believe this
is this has happened
and will happen again this is not
something where it's a dead end so isn't
the point I think you made it well isn't
the point
it isn't that those people all went on
to change the world
it's that in that mix that were some
went off and tried things in other
realms
whether it be retail or manufacturing or
he said most of them were doctors right
they were most but a lot of them most of
those guys did not go up and found out
right but they provided those providing
an environment and I know this is the
case for me there were this where stuff
happens if that environment doesn't
exist if I could tell you it doesn't
exist it gaku it doesn't exist as much
as it used to IBM in those places just
like it did that but these are just a
potential the primordial soup where
something might happen and you won't
necessarily even have see it happening
there but when you trace back from when
the changes come in this area you'll
find them running right through those I
was at a book party was this 93 or
something for Esther Dyson's book
release 2.0 it was held at the offices
of Kleiner Perkins Caufield buyer the
then premier venture capital firm Sand
Hill Road and a little man with glasses
came up to me and said you probably
don't remember me I used to attend the
meetings of the homebrew Computer Club
you know the many people do this and I'm
I learned the hard way that I have to be
polite and forthcoming and
congratulatory and so forth even when
they're trying to project on me things
that don't fit and it turned out this
was John doar he had been an engineer at
Intel in 1980 and attending the club
meetings whoops yes things happen don't
they
I of course tried to follow up on that
and see if I could get a job out of it
but that didn't work
he knew his business did a have fun over
here no okay I was gonna guess who this
small involve young man might be that I
spoiled it more discussion there kind of
a question about building communities
you just talk a little bit about how the
experience of how these communities get
started and well that's that's quite a
big question and sort of should be the
topic for it completely different talk
but it is of course related and you know
I don't have a five word answer to that
question it's a very big open question
but the important thing is that to bear
in mind that the stuff of community is
communication a community can be defined
as a group of people who communicate and
then parenthetically around some area on
a regular basis and if you take that
approach that's where I started with the
social media concepts that I helped
implement and I ran into enough people
who basically come to the same
conclusion as well that we are actually
able to try something so the important
element of creation of communities is to
recognize the process that's underway
and to set up structures that facilitate
the process or at least do not hamper it
so my example here the counter example
to the homebrew club is the Southern
California Computer Society and this you
probably never heard of them but with
good reason
they were organized according to run by
Robert's Rules of Order they had
officers they had budget so forth and so
on
they had a magazine which was interface
age I think and they had politics and
that really
completely frustrated anything that they
might have done
I remember being politic by some of
their people in a process that I really
didn't recognize and I don't think I was
any help to them but a Southern
California Computer Society this
dissolved in acrimonious politics the
magazine was taken away and had an
independent existence and so it might I
won't say that it might never might as
well not have existed I'm sure some
benefit came from it but it's very hard
to to find anyone who talked about it
well so if you you if you have the
opportunity to set up a real rigid
structure like that and one that's very
loose and open go for the open structure
there was a point when the homebrew club
incorporated and when the people in the
audience heard that I could see that
quite a number of them saying ah we're a
parliament now we get to vote and make
decisions and I spent some time that day
telling them no it's not going to be
that way this is my show and I can take
it anywhere I want nobody had told me it
was not my show and that pretty much put
the damper on the on their dreams of
empire well mostly it takes a
sensitivity to the communication that's
going on and that can go on I was
fortunate to at least listen to my
impulses and not participate in the flow
of information there that's the
interesting thing when people in the
John doors of the world come up to me
and they say I was in the meetings and
they were off
we'll say and you are saying a whole lot
of really important things well the fact
was that I said nothing of any
significance I simply took the role of
facilitator my job mostly was to keep
people from going on and on with the
what I call their primary information
what they really want to talk about the
structure was to try to associate
secondary information exchange which was
this is me I'm standing up so you can
see me that's what we had to do in the
pre-internet here and I want to talk
about this and that and that and that's
where it has to stop and the next person
gets up because when they start to say
and here's why then I speaking from the
front of the room have to exercise what
stagecraft I had learned and interject
jokes and so forth and break them and
that's what the in part the the infamous
pointer this is not the actual one it's
just one is symbolic and I learned how
to make gestures and so forth and twirl
it distract attention as though the
facilitation of the communication that
matters meaning analyze it in terms of I
mean I redid a two layer structure then
it could have been more I don't know how
you do that exactly but facilitating
makes all the difference and that means
not jumping into the actual primary
information flow John did you have
something discussing or aren't going to
make any breakthroughs by themselves
which is certainly true but there is
certainly precedent for organizations of
that sort serving only just be the
catalyst to bring together people who
didn't do something right one of the
inventors of the transistor start
company called Shockley transistor on
San Antonio Road which was meant to
commercialize the idea of these little
discrete transistors and because of his
name all of the best device physicists
in the world converged Mountbatten view
to work for this guy all the scientists
the doctorates and it only took them a
few months to realize that this isn't
what we should be doing but having
gotten there they that exploded like a
supernova exploding back out and little
groups of his fire bees went off to
start Fairchild or went off to start
Nationals from the connector or went off
you know two of the people that he
brought together it went off the farm in
tow right and chocolate transistor
itself founders floundered growth or it
is a fresh produce market now Atari was
doing things that were interesting with
small computers or home computers or
consumer computers or whatever and that
was remarkable at the time but it also
brought together people who looked at
what was going on and thought there
might be wow yeah you heard some people
that went on too far mother yeah he said
this is crap we can do better there we
go that's the operative phrase I mean
it's only when you get there and you
realize the this this isn't my vision my
vision would be something else but I
know people now that will help me
realize that how that you mentioned who
it was that you hired that it spun off
form other companies Oh some hippy Steve
Jobs I think yeah yeah yeah he was a
relatively well dressed young man when
he brought me in to see how looking for
a job and I didn't get the job in high
spirits
too bad yes in fact the inadequacy of
the technology and the inadequacy of the
circumstances I would argue is a an
important feature because it does not it
does more than draw people together it's
it sends them out it's kind of like a
reflux tale or something in chemistry
things returning and condensing and
coming back and so forth that TV
typewriter design it was nearly
impossible to get working and therefore
you learned so much more than you could
ever learn from a book and you of course
we're invested in it because you had to
buy the parts and put in the time
everybody who got you into the personal
computer industry or in a market in 1975
and they thought $300 would get you a
working computer on your desk or kitchen
table probably wouldn't have done it if
they had been told by the way you're
going to have to spend at least 10 times
that amount of money and a significant
portion of your spare time learning
things that you never realized you had
to learn and scrounging for whatever you
could get whenever you could get it that
wouldn't have been acceptable but they
were able to convince themselves hey I
can its own a magazine I can buy it and
get started that way and in fact it was
not a when you use the word convergent
but it's that's not quite real is less
the best metaphor is that it took on a
life of its own because it's people
doing it and not simply mathematical
functions and when people have to put in
effort they consider they're invested in
that and they all put in more effort so
I think that my point he really here is
yes you're right it's all amateurish but
that doesn't mean that nothing will
happen as a result things will happen as
a result and it would be very
interesting for people to go into it
looking with that
view point cradle Hey just finish the
sentence which is and because they
aren't trained to think of it a certain
way they will think of it anyway right
it's an advantage that starting as a
physician building a computer means you
think about it differently than someone
who was trained in data processing
I would love to interview some of those
physicians but I I wasn't there as a
historian the last most of us are
probably holding smartphones that are a
result of a lot of a lot of what we have
okay
I think limit now I guess well you know
you know I've known each other for a
couple of decades now and I think one of
the things I like I need you endorse
Steven Levy who wrote the book he was
the only person that I know who was
written about the valley in the industry
who identified to Southern California
Computer Society
I suspect you were probably the
participant at I was the source in
Southern California and I although I did
that was just before my time I think I
know people who were part of that my
question to you is do you think that the
vast majority of the people in the SCC
us were basically non-technical I can't
answer that for sure but I do know some
of them are pretty technical I mean they
had a reasonable core of technical
people but I never really I think the
old company that I can that I'm aware of
in the late 70s that came out of them
was very briefly ashton-tate that that
nobody ever heard of them well big deal
for yes debased
yeah one of them was a parent right
probably yeah okay
I don't know who whether it was Ashton
or take but anyway that no it was very
limited you know stick abate identified
I cannot answer the question about
analyzing their their membership because
I simply didn't do the words that the
some of this is happening on Quora
right now with both spin-offs in the Los
Angeles area spin-offs in the San Diego
area
you know startups and the light and
they're all scratching their heads and
they had no idea of the SEC s the other
thing that I wonder about it and getting
back to make her fair and alike is you
want to say anything about the demise of
shop classes in public schools will do
and the definite I don't think is a big
deal
for these things because I grew up a
shot classes I had metal shop wood shop
so forth electric shop and and he could
Diagon Hades right I in fact learned
much of electronics by reading a book
which was nothing but manuals collected
manuals for kits and I finally got the
point of this connection between a
schematic diagram and the pictorial the
wiring diagram and the availability of
kits of hands-on materials that when you
built them they eventually worked I
think is a really important factor in
learning I mean I think you've set me up
for something I wanted to say and didn't
have the and have the opening now I've
got it in terms of learning
well the real learning period is the
middle school years I believe certainly
it happened to me when I was 12 I was
given through a phantasmagoric stroke of
luck a cast-off correspondence course
for radio TV
hair which actually included test
equipment that arrived by mail you know
the the chances of that happening are
some are infinitesimal well alright
leave they there that metaphysical
question aside but that was the right
age for me to be studying my way into
that and of course I was a real jerk
about that I ostentatiously studied the
booklets and so forth in school and
disciplined by the teachers for doing so
and but but that is the age where
learning makes a tremendous push and
what are we providing for kids to learn
with these days now a lot of what there
is can be found at Maker Faire I can
tell you that kids and so forth but a
lot of those of course I have never
heard of most of them and I have come to
the conclusion that I would make it my
goal to try to make logic design a
matter of common knowledge at least
available as common knowledge for middle
school students so the theory being when
you when kids entered high school they
had had experience or had the
opportunity to have experience with
logic design and that to me as an
engineer unfolds into okay what tool you
what device do you make and I'm working
on a state machine with an 8-bit state
machine it's really a reconstruction of
the sixteen are eight programmable array
logic PA ELLs from monolithic memories
now they're called PL DS because PA l
was trademarked and programmed with
tweezers and minnie mouse diodes in a
matrix using a technology that is
basically 1960s vintage
with 1970s vintage medium scale
integration chips in there and LEDs
showing all the intermediate terms and I
know that monolithic memories the guy
who really did this was John Brickner
bir k NER and I can't locate him now I
don't know what's happened but I find
any reference to him on Google
but they published books of projects
things like coin acceptor logic and
things of that sort
I'd love to get my hands on one of those
books but if not there's plenty of
talent around to think up projects like
that
so I take the approach that you need to
have the artifact and then you can start
developing the the manifestations of it
but the idea would be that one of my
heroes from childhood was Charles
Proteus Steinmetz
he was a hunchback dwarf from the German
refugee basically in the 1890s he
established really Electrical
Engineering in the US he came in where
all these electricians as they defined
themselves did not know how to calculate
alternating current they said and I
remember my thinking that when I was 12
like but it goes this way and it goes
that way the average is zero III don't
know how to calculate it and he invented
and you made the point about
root-mean-square power and so forth he
brought mathematics into electrical
engineering and he worked for General
Electric
if you hey he had quite good publicity
and I reinvest I read a book about him
when I was a kid well some of the
lectures he gave around that time were
published and I ran into one of them in
the 60s I think and a used book shelf
and it said that there were this was the
third of three lectures the first two
lectures are no longer published because
they are considered common knowledge or
general they're so well known well I
want to move logic design into that
position what do you mean books on it
everybody knows it well that would be
nice see it's a goal
and it's possible I think with proper
design and paying attention to how
people play with it to do that one of
the places I can do that and I must
write that out now as a kind of parting
shot is hack the future this was started
by Matt Spergel son of Marty Spergel the
junkman
I think is heck the future org but
you'll have to try that let's see where
and this is where every few months we
have a an event at mostly it's been the
tech museum but it's also likely to be
once at least in a computer history
museum bring in 200 or 100 kids aged 11
to 18 I think and have mentors there who
helped them basically have a hackathon
how comes there and teaches them
soldering I have my prototype of my
state machine for the purpose of my
learning how kids deal with this stuff
and guess what I found out that they do
not pick up the handout and read through
it I have yet to have one kid do that so
on we go for that I have to learn how
they're going to learn if I'm going to
be of any use to them I thought final
the whole overview topic hears of the
maker movement the MakerBot type things
3d assemblies 3d programming languages
these are all emerging technologies and
the fun thing about a new technology is
that people don't know where it said it
I was lucky enough to be in Silicon
Valley mid 70s onward and they're really
I know I'm probably something like an
old geezer but there were there was a
sort of a golden age when
microprocessors came out small computers
came out early personal computers came
out where the challenge in getting a
complex system to work is to make the
right trade-offs you can't do everything
you want and so there were literally
dozens of microprocessor vendors coming
up with whole different approaches to
what processor architecture should be
like there were hundreds of piece of
companies selling computers to consumers
and some of them were in kit form or
some were partly assembled or some were
just circuit boards or somewhere hold
boxes or something where things were use
in the kitchen or somewhere things that
had keyboards built in I mean it if you
can find a circa 1980 early 1980
magazine and look through the ads it's
astounding how many different visions
there were of where the industry was
headed and how the technology could be
reshaped in two different ways and then
in August of 81 is when IBM introduced
the first personal computer which was
sort of a critical mass that had the
effect of instantly stopping on
everything that wasn't it the volume was
Soviet I mean it suddenly they created
an expectation of what a personal
computers would be partner was to go
three so ostentatious today this is the
IBM PC which stands for personal
computer everything that came before
doesn't count very quickly God ignored
or abandoned because now people had a
common knowledge or common expectation
of what it was they're willing to spend
money for that seemed like a real bad
thing at the time in the sense that all
the other exploration and
experimentation was now snuffed out a
lot of people think that that catalyzing
event is what made the industry viable
and led to Intel for instance being able
to afford to continue the research that
it was doing one question is something
like I don't know if the IBM PC would
have been the supernova or a black hole
weather
added created something or something
whether it be a catalyzing event related
to 3d construction MakerBot's this event
that be good or bad you won't recognize
it until after it's happened that's the
nature of those things I don't see why
not
I mean there will be several because the
maker phenomenon is broader in it in the
technologies that it deals with then
personal computers were and then there
is no one playing in the field as there
was IBM in that field in the field of
computers that event was we knew about
it at the time because they published
their rom code in the manual and to
those of us who had spent the last five
years inveighing against IBM and the way
they did things they have suddenly
reversed their way of doing things well
one bargain it might have been yes
that's some little or little outfit in
Boca Raton it doesn't make any change in
what the whole company is doing and of
course now IBM appears to be it's more
or less of a Linux shop now that's kind
of the both the victory and defeat of it
all I don't know how to actually judge
that but in fact IBM no longer has the
same hegemony position that they did at
that time so that it was very weird when
it happened you knew something was
happening here but as they say they
don't know what it is mr. Jones and I am
sure that things like that will happen
in the larger yet to have a good name
except we call it now makers phenomenon
I'm pulling back holding back from
calling again movement for reasons I
won't go into now but that's it more or
less sir
sentimental reasons the trouble is that
you only really get to identify them in
retrospect I don't know about that I
disagree I mean I did come from the
personal computer market but I mean I
was a freshman in college and I saw this
thing called the ARPANET work and from
that moment on I knew that was the
future well you're a bit strange welcome
all of us who were exposed to the
ARPANET were that way yeah with certain
degree I mean that's the tradition that
Google and Yahoo came out of then I
forget mosaic and that's it yes of
course I mean communication is what it's
all about in my view and that clearly
was communication now as a new I almost
want to say technology but I would say a
new universe of communication well it
was but the thing is you know this is
why the reason you and I ever at this
conference in November that I was I did
the last session for yeah part of the
reason why recently I speak was it was
government-funded research and I heard
these names like Bob Kahn and Bob Taylor
and they were like hi as we bowed to
3,000 miles away and at the same time
those people got a lot of criticism from
both IBM and AT&T is that this will
never work
yeah no it was well known what was going
to work and not only that they said our
solution is this thing called SNA we're
token ring or any variety of other
things which have all since failed
that's right now in 1978 a bunch of
people from various disciplines or if
some of us were recruited on the floor
of the computer shows and Ted Nelson was
one of them I was there
tour often hilts make creators of the
first real conferencing system and a
number of very significant minds were
brought together at a secret conference
in the stone house in Rhode Island this
was
made known to me secretly was funded by
IBM and they were interested in what we
would how it respond to the idea of
video discs as the the technology for
communication and we did we beheld we
discussed it for two days and came to
the conclusion that video discs didn't
amount to a hill of beans what you
really wanted to do was computer
networks and the word I got back many
years later was that the the big name in
IBM whose idea this was was felt
completely offended and completely
ignored it so when there are people who
know how things are going to be done you
can be pretty sure they're wrong they
will have nice jobs and published books
and have a nice careers telling people
how things are going to be done but it
will almost always be done a different
way and there's where I have to leave it
because otherwise I'm telling you how
things will be done I think we're out of
time thank you
you